it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning he is back from his holidays
ready to tackle the cost of living
crisis secure starmer is focusing on how
to shrink our winter energy bills but i
would later pay for it i'll be asking
the shadow financial secretary to the
treasury james murray
plus with reports some from team trust
are dismissing it as socialism will be
asking one of her supporters the former
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
exactly what he makes of the policy
plus one year on from the fall of kabul
we'll be there live to ask whether or
not we can trust the taliban now i'll be
speaking to the former head of the army
general lord dammit shortly and at half
past now i'll be joined by a former
afghan interpreter who worked with the
british army and was forced to go into
hiding after the takeover also a former
royal marine that helped to extract
diplomats during last year's evacuation
it is monday the 15th of august
playing hardball the labour leader vows
that people won't pay a penny more on
their winter bills as he reveals how he
would get energy costs under control
chaos confusion and avoidable outcomes
criticism of the us-led withdrawal from
afghanistan on the first anniversary of
the taliban takeover our chief
correspondent will be reporting on a
crisis in the country's hospitals
many of the children who come here are
simply going to die not because they
couldn't be treated but because there is
no way of treating them they need
international community health
weather warnings but now for thunder and
lightning as here in the south downs
national park there are calls to ban
disposable barbecues to protect the land
from heat
a most joyful soul the family of anhesh
paid tribute to the star after her life
support is switched off nine days after
a car crash
his feisty and defiant sense of humor is
back as salman rushdie's son updates on
his father's progress we'll be asking is
free speech under threat after
this comment from the governor of new
york i want it out there
that a man with a knife cannot silence a
man with a pen
we're in kenya's national tallying
center as the country anxiously awaits
to find out who will be their next
president
also ahead on the program
touchline buster
chelsea and spurs managers face-off
takes a new twist
as manchester united lick their wounds
after a somewhat shaky start to the
season i'll be talking football at
quarter tonight
[Music]
welcome back to westeros the game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon
premieres today we'll take you behind
the scenes with the actors
[Music]
morning all
it is the big reveal we've been waiting
for from the labour leader
his plans to tackle rising energy bills
secure starman has pledged that people
will not be paying a penny more as he
prepares to officially unveil labour's
plan for easing the cost of living
crisis
well recent data shows that the energy
prices could rise again to 3 600 pounds
in october
and almost as high as 4
300 pounds by january
setting out his emergency plan to tackle
the cost of living crisis the labour
leader is expected to say the party
would freeze the energy price cap at its
current level of 1 971 pounds this they
say will save the average household a
thousand quid now it says its energy
plans are fully costed and will be paid
for by removing a major tax loophole in
the windfall tax announced by the then
chancellor rishi sunak a little earlier
this year
as you can see our political
correspondent tamara cohen joins me in
the studio morning tomorrow good to see
you big idea it is a big idea and labour
know they will need a big idea to keep
the pressure on the government over this
issue essentially they're saying that
the current level of the price cap just
under two thousand pounds would be kept
frozen for six months if they were in
government we know it's due to go up due
to double by the beginning of next year
so they it's simple it's easy to
understand they say it would save the
average household a thousand pounds and
they also say it's fully funded from
increasing the windfall tax from getting
rid of some of the measures the
government has announced his 400 pound
cost of living payment and they say
inflation would be lower others say
they're not so sure of that but
certainly it puts this issue freezing it
all together on the agenda and will put
the pressure on rishi sunak and list
trust to say what they would do and why
they think this isn't a good idea we've
already had liz truss's
allies saying it is a socialist idea
yeah we'll be speaking to james murray
about that and eight o'clock tomorrow
night thanks very much indeed
now today marks 12 months since the
taliban drove into the afghan capital
with guns and rocket launchers held to
the sky in celebration
now the country is facing economic
collapse and a nationwide medical crisis
in addition a new report from the u.s
led withdrawal it says it was full of
chaos and confusion and ended in
avoidable outcomes that from republicans
on the u.s house foreign affairs
committee
were more than half the country's
population that's 24 million people need
humanitarian assistance
the united nations says 160 people have
been killed by the taliban since last
year that despite
an amnesty pledge
under the country's new leaders
afghanistan lost 6.5 billion pounds in
aid and has been blocked from its gold
and cash reserves now that's left 90 of
afghanistan's health clinics on the
brink of shutting down sky news has
heard pleas from doctors and indeed from
the taliban for increased international
support our chief correspondent stuart
ramsey who was there of course when the
capital fell sent this report from the
biggest children's hospital in the
country first a warning it does contain
images of malnourished children
this is a medical emergency and every
day it's getting worse here
critically ill children are squeezed
into cots two or three at a time there's
just not enough room and there are too
many patients in desperate need and
every day more are coming
this is the top children's hospital in
afghanistan it's the best there is but
they're running out of everything
medicine supplies equipment everything
medical staff know they just can't treat
their patients but they keep trying
anyway they're all very poorly these
little ones
[Music]
and it's difficult but are their chances
of survival quite low
treatments no treatment
[Music]
there's over 500 patients in the indira
gandhi hospital they've only room for
300.
ward after ward is exactly the same
jam-packed with really poorly babies and
children
foreign aid lost after the taliban
takeover is critical if they are to save
lives
there's a need for
some good drugs yes you don't purchase
from
outside the hospital and this is a big
problem our peoples like these are very
poor we have need some like we need for
ventilator machine we don't have
ventilator
[Music]
aziz struggles to pick up his daughter
and place her next to her brother
they've come from two provinces to get
here
they've genetic kidney disease like two
of their siblings already dead the
chance of
survivors
too low
i mean
eighty percent uh chance of dying
every day you're coming to work knowing
there's nothing you can do
for these patients unfortunately no
well and it must be terrible
so you don't have to get out of the way
many have serious illnesses that could
be successfully treated it's not a lack
of skill here it's a lack of resources
healthcare in afghanistan particularly
in the provinces has been poured for
decades that isn't the issue here the
point is we're in the best children's
hospital
in the whole of the country and they're
overwhelmed they just don't have the
resources they don't have the money they
don't have medicines and
many of the children who come here are
simply going to die not because they
couldn't be treated but because there is
no way of treating them they need
international community help
the taliban are in charge here indeed an
armed guard was assigned to us the whole
time it's one of the problems for the
international community
despite the taliban's intransigent
position on many issues the hospital's
president himself a surgeon is asking
for help with this medical crisis
um
[Music]
a woman grabbed us
she wanted help to buy baby food can
[Music]
[Music]
hospital doesn't have formula
it's really
not ill enough to be admitted
malnutrition across afghanistan is out
of control
the worst affected come here if they can
make it
sofia is seven
she's just arrived
but for the first time in weeks the
family has some hope are you hopeful
that she will get better
for many others though there is nothing
but despair
malnutrition has engulfed two-year-old
shireen khan's body
he's fighting for his life his mom can
do nothing
this is a nationwide medical emergency
golbasha doesn't care who's to blame
she just wants her son to live
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
now we're joined once again on the
programme for the former head of the
british army lord danette lord dana
lovely to see you this morning um
a year on from the fall of kabul um the
home secretary pretty patel has has been
expressing her tremendous pride about
the government's afghanistan
government's evacuation did you share in
that pride with the benefit of of course
of hindsight
well um
i've got huge pride
in the way that uh the soldiers that we
sent to kabul uh carried out their
duties in what was undeniably a chaotic
situation yes we managed to get quite a
number of entitled people out but we
left a tremendous number of people there
but you know neil this begs a whole
wider question
why did that happen why were those
circumstances allowed to take place
frankly
i believed at the time it was
unnecessary a year later it was
unnecessary and as your report has shown
afghanistan is in terrible condition at
the present moment
and if we reflect on why we spent 20
years in afghanistan uh yes we achieved
what we originally wanted to achieve
which was to contain al-qaeda so they
couldn't carry out more attacks in the
west but most particularly we spent
those 20 years building up afghan
society giving afghan society afghan
people a future and some hope
and it is therefore tragic that we quite
unnecessarily withdrew in precipitate
haste
a year ago
but then
i think absolutely outrageously
have cut aid to afghanistan such that
the people
the babies around the condition that
your film has just shown
right across the country people are
starving we went there to help the
afghan people and now we're just
actually watching them suffer i think
it's outrageous and i think
pretty patel and other members of the
government should take no pride in what
is happening there they should be
starting again as should the americans
who are principally responsible for what
happened should be significantly
increasing their aid packages again to
allow the people to to have food and to
thrive in afghanistan and not to have
television films such as you've shown
everybody showing what pitiful condition
that they're in um is there pride yes
pride in our soldiers is their pride in
what our government and international
governments are doing not at all
yeah i'm watching stewart's report this
morning before coming on the program
it's difficult not to to have been moved
by it but just talk a little bit more
then about your experience in country
the the assistance that the british did
give during that 20-year period i was on
the ground a few times with with british
forces saw the hearts and minds efforts
saw the education of children in a way
which hadn't had never been done before
all of that progress it would seem has
now been rolled back by a taliban that
resembles the taliban of 2001
yes i think we all have to acknowledge
that the taliban are repressive
but
again it comes back to the question
we went to afghanistan to help the
people of afghanistan now we're making
films watching the people of afghanistan
suffer yes we may not like the taliban
we may not like their attitude i
certainly don't towards women and girls
and stopping girls going to secondary
education
but
just because we don't like their human
rights record and of course it's a big
issue but because we don't like their
human rights record and the number of
things that they're doing we're
withholding
aid from the people of that country such
that babies are dying people are
starving and
it's not for want of food in the country
it's for want of money to be able to buy
it we have starved the place of cash
in an economy that was made up by about
80 percent of international aid forming
the cash flow of that country so we
could change this we could stop this we
actually could help the people of
afghanistan and i believe that um
diplomats and statesmen should be
thinking seriously about starting aid
again to afghanistan and using that aid
to leverage
on the taliban to get them to change
some of the
attitudes that they take particularly
towards women and girls and girls
secondary education
just to be clear though about what
you're saying there lord danette i mean
given the fact that 60 of of afghanistan
is currently suffering from malnutrition
their gold reserves are still frozen
there has been a stop to aid i mean are
we in the west then essentially
responsible perhaps even more
responsible than the taliban for what
stewart was seeing in the hospitals
well put it bluntly
the american decision initially by
donald trump and then agreed by joe
biden
that the americans would leave
afghanistan by august last year which
was a unilateral decision about which we
were not consulted and other partners
were not consulted that decision
directly led to the collapse of the
afghan national army the afghan national
police and allowed the taliban to take
over the country that having happened
the west has said we don't like the
taliban so we're going to cut off aid to
this country and having cut off aid to
afghanistan that is why babies are dying
in hospitals that is why people are
starving up and down the country now is
that right
as i said before and we spent 20 years
building up
afghanistan afghanistan society we spent
20 years helping the people why should
we suddenly stop helping the people now
because we don't like the taliban
frankly
yes their human rights record is not
good they have stopped second girls
going to secondary school but is that
the right price to pay for the majority
of afghan people to be starving and
babies to be dying i don't think so i
think we've got this terribly wrong and
governments need to wake up start the
flow of aid again and
give the afghan people for whom we tried
to help them for 20 years give them a
prospect of a future while bearing down
on the taliban to say come on you
actually got to behave like a civilized
country a civilized government or
otherwise um you'll never take your
proper place in the world
it's part of the situation that we're
seeing at the moment perhaps that much
that many of the world's eyes are
elsewhere in fact afghanistan is a topic
rarely discussed around the dinner
tables these days i mean last august you
were speaking to us on the channel you
said something terrible will happen
elsewhere the world's media will move on
and this is when the taliban will
enforce their harsh regime i mean did
that happen in terms of ukraine
well of course it did
the disasters emergency committee for
example launched an appeal this time
last year to raise funds for afghanistan
but quite quickly come february this
year they launched an appeal for ukraine
and that
raised over 300 million pounds um and
it's not as if it's ukraine that's
actually pushed afghanistan off the news
now the cost of living crisis and the
and the energy uh cost increases have
always pushed ukraine off the news we
are very short-termist in terms of our
of our intervention and it comes back to
my basic point
we spent 20 years trying to build up
afghan society and help afghan people
why do we walk away now and watch films
a year on such as the one that you're
showing people this morning of babies
dying and people starving frankly we've
got to be prepared to have longer
engagements in this country if we think
human life is worth preserving otherwise
we'll just watch them all perish
lord dana always a pleasure to talk to
you thanks for joining us this morning
and as uh previously mentioned i'll be
speaking to our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey who's in kabul at half
past seven of course one year on since
he witnessed the taliban enter kabul
whilst he was live on air
i hear a lot of shouting uh
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban uh yes it is there's the
white flag
and uh
they're coming down uh the street
uh just next to us they're in their
xiaowa comes they're led by a white flag
um and they're chanting
as they as they go
now a yellow weather warning is in place
across most of the country with
forecasters predicting thunder lightning
and floods which could pose
further danger following days of extreme
heat and wildfires
down here in the south though it looks
like another hot day is forecast here's
a look over the london skyline looking
gorgeous this morning but let me tell
you it is roasting out there
i will let's speak now to sky's sava
chowdhury who's in the south towns
national park for us this morning where
there are calls to ban disposable
barbecues to protect the precious
landscape saba very good morning to you
and what a lovely backdrop it is as well
but of course those disposable barbecues
could make that backdrop look rather
different frankly
good morning yes absolutely let me tell
you a little bit about where i am so i'm
at the south downs uh national park as
you mentioned where it's still looking
very parched uh very dry very yellow but
potentially for not much longer and
that's because there are three yellow
weather warnings uh in england and wales
and also they're currently in place in
scotland and northern ireland so plenty
of downpour a contrast to the weather
the hot weather we've been experiencing
uh recently
but this is you know a relief i'm sure
for the likes of firefighters for water
companies for hospitals you know uh
groups and uh services to society that
have had their work cut out for them uh
recently but it's gonna take a lot of
work to undo some of the damage that has
been caused as a result
of the recent heat that we have
been witnessing and it's why think tank
or the green alliance are calling on the
government to pay farmers to help
cultivate some of england's at least
productive uh soils and that's to help
uh protect animals to protect uh the
land and it's also the small things you
mentioned a national ban on barbecues
well it's what the national park here
are advocating for and they're saying
listen we've had plenty of fires here
and we can't enforce people to stop but
we simply only in our current capacity
can advise so it's a combination of both
the small the local and the national uh
level so uh in all if you are going out
this week which i'm sure plenty of our
viewers will be be prepared for all
weather that's what i'm going to say
that's something some sage advice in
council thanks abba
a quick look at what's making the
morning's front pages uh starting with
the sun drip drip tray their headline uh
about the news that rain is starting to
fall in some parts of the uk
after the heat wave
the metro has the headline freeze at not
talking about the weather instead
discussing cure starman's promise to
block the rise in energy belts
the mirror leads with an exclusive
interview with the labour leader he's
been telling the paper that the uk is
now facing a national emergency
here's the times it claims that three
and four conservative voters support
labour's energy plan
the eye leads with the headline sunak
and truss under pressure to cut the
price cap as the two candidates face
further calls to tackle rising energy
bills
still to come on the programme i'll be
speaking to the shadow financial
secretary to the treasury james murray
about the labour leaders cost of living
crisis plan
[Music]
the former northern ireland secretary
and liz trust supporter brandon lewis
will be here a little later what does he
make labour's plan to tackle rising
energy bills
[Music]
a year after the taliban took control of
kabul i'll be speaking to a former
interpreter who worked with the british
army he was forced into hiding in
afghanistan when nato forces left
some of the days other news now and the
actress anne hesh has been taken off
life support in the united states the 53
year old had been deemed legally dead
nine days after crashing her car into a
house in los angeles
doctors say she was kept alive so that
her organs could be used for transplant
one of the actresses best known roles
was in the gangster film donnie brasco
she also starred in the disaster
thriller
thriller volcano and alongside harrison
ford in the romantic comedy six days and
seven nights
in a statement her family said this we
have lost a bright light a kind and most
joyful soul a loving mother and a loyal
friend
and will be deeply missed that she lives
on through her beautiful sons her iconic
body of work
and her passionate advocacy
a man with a knife cannot silence a man
with a pen those the words of the
governor of new york state after the
authors of salman rushdie was stabbed
whilst on stage at an event his son says
he is still feisty and defiant despite
those life-changing injuries
i want it out there
that a man with a knife cannot silence a
man with a pen
mr rush he spent more than a decade of
his life in hiding and finally said no
more i'm coming out
i'm coming out of the shadows
i will not be bowed by fear
or a threat
and to those of us who go about our
daily lives
if that's not an inspiration i don't
know what is
well sky's david blevins is at the
hospital in erie pennsylvania where
salman rushdie is being treated
it's been a very difficult weekend for
salman rushdie's family they're still at
his bedside in this hospital in
pennsylvania immediately after the
attack on friday he was placed on a
ventilator and was unable to speak but
his son sapphire says he's now off the
ventilator and has been able to say a
few words he added that despite the fact
that he's still being treated for
serious injuries he hasn't lost his
defiant and feisty sense of humor we
learned more about those injuries when
24 year old had a matar from new jersey
appeared in court charged with the
attempted murder of the author he denies
that charge and will appear in court
again later this week but the court
heard salman rushdie had been stabbed
approximately 12 times in his eye neck
chest and abdomen
he was of course living under the
sentence of death for more than 30 years
imposed by the iranian leader ayatollah
khomeini following the publication of
his novel the satanic verses many
muslims felt his portrayal of the
prophet muhammad was blasphemous but in
recent years he felt most of the danger
had passed and that it was safe enough
for him to speak at events like the
literary festival where he was due to
give a lecture on friday
a lecture in which he would have been
doing what he has done for a very long
time championed the cause of freedom of
speech
uh more than that throughout the day of
course uh but some of the day's other
headlines and the delegation of u.s
politicians has arrived in taiwan less
than two weeks after house speaker nancy
pelosi's visit which of course stoked
high tension with china
their two-day trip will include a
meeting with the taiwanese president
which claims that
beijing which claims taiwan as its own
territory has accused the u.s of
provoking instability
the olympic sprinter ricardo dos santos
has accused the metropolitan police of
racial profiling after his car was
stopped by what he described as seven
armed officers just awarding these
pictures the athletes shared of the
incident on social media do contain a
bit of flash photography
uh well it is the second time that dos
santos has been searched by police in
the capital in two years
the met say they believe the driver of
the car was on the phone
and tweeted to dos santos that they'd
like to discuss the matter further
russia's president has told north korean
leader kim jong-un that
closer ties between their two countries
will be in both their interests
the repair can be seen
here back in 2019
the state news agency in pyongyang
reported details for the letter from
moscow to mark north korea's liberation
day in that letter vladimir putin said
the nations will expand constructive
bilateral relations to strengthen the
stability of the korean peninsula and of
north east asia
and who could forget
this particular meeting back in 2018
the then leader of the free world donald
trump
secured a meeting with kim jong-un
which took place in singapore following
the summit president trump announced
that joint u.s and south korean military
exercises being held at the time were to
be discontinued also adding that north
korea korea was in his view no longer a
nuclear threat there were more meetings
between the two leaders afterwards
including in june 2019 when mr trump
became the first sitting president to
set foot in the korean demilitarized
zone many hoped it was a sign of better
things to come
maybe not
now scientists say they have made a
significant breakthrough in kidney
transplant research a team at the
university of cambridge have
successfully altered the blood type of
three donor kidneys which could increase
the supply of organs particularly within
ethnic minority groups who are much less
likely to find a match skies shinge
maruriki has been taking a closer look
for more than two decades aisha has
lived with chronic kidney disease
she's now retired and mainly housebound
the simple things are struggles
while the transplant she desperately
needs could take a decade during the
pandemic is that's when i was told that
i had 12 months to find a living kidney
donor
and although i already knew that my
condition was um heading that way it was
still a bit of a shock because i think
that no matter how much you prepare when
you get a news like that you know it's
tough it's it's tough going
but now she's been given a boost by some
scientific success researchers have
altered the blood types on three
deceased donor kidneys
it's not a clinical trial stage yet
but the discovery looks like this
a kidney from someone with blood type a
can't be transplanted to someone with
blood type b or vice versa
scientists from the university of
cambridge use a machine to flush the
donated kidney of oxygenated blood and
infuse it with an enzyme that can remove
blood type markers
changing the blood type to the universal
o will allow more transplants to take
place as this can be used with any blood
type
the nhs says last year just over nine
percent of total organ donations came
from black and minority ethnic donors
while they make up 33 of the kidney
transplant waiting list people from
ethnic minority backgrounds on average
wait a year longer to receive the kidney
transplant than people from a caucasian
background so again if this research
helps to redress that balance that would
be absolutely fantastic
it's news that has given aisha hope for
the future
but she also has this urgent message in
the present for minorities unsure about
organ donation because of stigmas and a
lack of awareness you're giving someone
a chance to live their life normally to
be able to work to be able to raise a
family to be able to have wonderful
adventures in life and you can't you
really can't you know argue with that
if a community can be convinced to come
forward and science keeps taking strides
so many more lives could be saved shinki
marike sky news
let's take you back to that extreme
weather that's been sweeping across the
country uh let's speak now to sky
meteorologist joe wheeler who joins us
now joe lovely to see you so it looks
like it's all about to change in fact in
parts of the country it already has
it is already changing certainly a very
different look to this morning here on
the east coast there's far more in the
way of cloud in the sky and yesterday of
course we developed these thunderstorms
over scotland became an amber alert very
quickly and some torrential downpours
but let's take a look at what's in store
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well yes it is all change over the next
few days we've got thunderstorms
developing from the northwest and then
this evening further thunderstorms
coming up from the southwest an area of
low pressure not only the thunderstorms
we're going to drag in the energy with
that low pressure as well because it's
going to bring in a lot of very warm air
from the south
so we're looking at these thunderstorms
through the course of the day could
happen anywhere parts of scotland are
looking at around 60 to 80 millimeters
of rainfall over the next 48 hours or so
where you get these thunderstorms
torrential downpours the likelihood of
flash flooding because the ground is so
very dry also horrible conditions on the
roads and that thunderstorm warning goes
on into tomorrow and wednesday for the
south
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now let's take a quick look at some of
the pictures of the day how did you
spend your weekend well with warnings of
thunderstorms people were making the
most of the sunny weather down at south
end on sea wonderful it looks as well
however the hot weather certainly wasn't
good news for everyone over the weekend
several assets at the bristol
international balloon fiesta were
cancelled but yesterday morning we've
got a snapshot of a few of them here
emerging from the ground 63 hot air
balloons managed to take to the skies
over the southwest stunning
now from ascent to descent this dog
called maggie triggered a five-hour
rescue mission on ben nevis after she
refused to trek back down the mountain
due to her sore paws per thing she was
eventually brought down in a stretcher
by rescuers
welcome back
speaking to the programme just a little
earlier this morning the former head of
the british army said the situation in
afghanistan is terrible lord danette
told me that it is outrageous in his
view how aid has been cut to the country
we quite unnecessarily withdrew in
precipitate haste
a year ago but then i think absolutely
outrageously
have cut aid to afghanistan
such that the people
the babies around the condition that
your film has just shown
right across the country people are
starving we went there to help the
afghan people and now we're just
actually watching them suffer i think
it's outrageous and i think pretty patel
and other members of the government
should take no pride in what is
happening there they should be starting
again as should the americans who are
principally responsible for what
happened should be significantly
increasing their aid packages again to
allow the people to to have food and to
thrive in afghanistan and not to have
television films such as you've shown
everybody showing what pitiful condition
that they are in um is their pride yes
pride in our soldiers is their pride in
what our government and international
governments are doing not at all
well let's stick with the situation in
afghanistan a year of course after the
taliban took control of kabul one man
who was there and i think pretty much
standing exactly the same position by
the licks of the shots it's stewart
ramsey our chief correspondent i'm
stuart i mean anyone who hasn't seen
your report this morning i'd urge to go
onto the website and and get a good view
of just how catastrophic a situation is
emerging in afghanistan's hospitals but
speaking about that and speaking more
generally in the 12 months since you
spotted the taliban marching into kabul
how have things changed there
well it's interesting because all the
sort of paraphernalia of security for
example the blast walls and the
checkpoints are all still in place but
of course they're now controlled by the
taliban but there is that sense of still
being at war even though there isn't
actually a war uh taking place though
islamic state is still very much here
and there are bombs fairly regularly
in in kabul i think what really has
struck me is the economy i mean it
really really is in absolute free fall
and uh the working classes in the middle
classes are really suffering as well
there's always been huge poverty in
afghanistan but now it is really really
bad as lord dana was saying there you
know for 20 years we've pumped billions
of dollars into the into the country aid
agents with aid agencies were here in
huge numbers and that all pretty much
stopped and at least there's now a
trickle coming through and the effect is
that uh the economy and the ordinary
people are suffering incredibly now the
taliban are in control and so there's
almost an ideological problem from
western governments for them being here
but they might be perceived to be the
enemy but the afghan people are not and
they're the ones who are actually
suffering the most certainly not the
taliban themselves but virtually
everyone else
in this country is now really really
suffering and as you saw in my report uh
the medical uh part of the country is is
absolutely horrendous malnutrition rates
are going up people are starving across
the country and it's getting worse
literally by the day
stuart many thanks and deeds and of
course we'll have much more on this in
fact we're going to stay with the topic
joining us now uh michael keaton former
un deputy envoy to afghanistan now
executive director at the european
institute of peace michael great to have
you on this morning um
just speaking to stuart ramsey there in
kabul took me straight back to those
early days of of the takeover by the
taliban when they moved in
to kabul they say you know we have
changed we have changed a lot i i'd
suggest that perhaps the evidence of the
past 12 months is that they haven't
well unfortunately there's a hard core
of taliban that have not changed
but there are a lot more pragmatists i
think now
than perhaps there were
certainly uh uh 20 years ago let's not
forget that the taliban were in charge
between 96 and 2001
so they have some experience of
governing but of course afghanistan has
dramatically changed since then it's a
much more populated country bigger
economy
it's had the experience of the last 20
years
young people particularly women going to
school and so on so it's a different
place the problem is that the
pragmatists are locking horns with the
conservatives uh and they are not
winning the political case
uh in terms of things like women's
rights and exclu more inclusive
government
and until there is progress on these
issues it seems unlikely that the west
will
unfreeze the bank and gold reserves
allow aids to flow into the country
freely i mean do you agree with that
approach
uh well look the the
stuart was talking about humanitarian
crisis and unfortunately it's going to
get a lot worse this coming winter
uh i'm speaking to you actually from
the ukrainian
border uh the ukraine effect is going to
be dramatic there are many other parts
of the world that are facing
uh food security it means that the
common interest that many countries have
in stabilizing
afghanistan is being challenged by all
sorts of issues in the security council
[Music]
it means that attention on afghanistan
it's great that there's all this
coverage because of the one-year
anniversary but on the whole afghanistan
is slipping away
and off the agenda
so i really do worry about uh the
humanitarian situation and even the
ability to meet uh you know humanitarian
needs the u.n keeps issuing these
whopping great appeals
uh but even those are not being met uh
and i suspect uh they will
short fall short even further but the
main point is you're not going to be
able to resolve the humanitarian crisis
with humanitarian aid what you need is
to get the economy functioning you need
to get government functioning and that
can't be done with humanitarian aid so
in my view
the important thing is to recognize that
whether we like it or not the taliban
are a reality and to continue to try and
find ways to engage with them to make
sure that the population doesn't yet
once again
suffer
terribly what concrete steps then can we
take as a
as the western community what can we
take what steps can we take to ensure
that there is at least progress towards
an effective government in afghanistan
well it is a tough one um i mean you you
talk about concrete steps concrete steps
of course include maintaining the
humanitarian aid then i think there need
to be discussions about practical things
that are most important to the majority
of the people getting the agricultural
production back up getting
uh you know investing in
uh jobs uh trying to
rebuild some of the smaller
infrastructure things things that are
generate generate work and income for
people
because often it's not the lack of stuff
in markets that's the issue people just
simply don't have the means to to buy it
but for this to happen there has to be a
political engagement and the taliban
have to be
uh persuaded that it is in their
interest certainly it's in interest the
population
to get the
banking system
functional on a basis is acceptable to
the international community that's
prepared to put money back into the
country
that it's prepared to allow technocrats
to work not into fear and above all
you know you can't expect western
taxpayers
to continue providing or resume
providing development systems
unless
basic rights
particularly of women
are being met so there has to be a
you know concretely engagement with the
taliban it's going to be a long haul
ultimately if the taliban are going to
change it's because of
politics within the taliban movement so
you know what we need to do is is is is
encourage those who are seeking a more
pragmatic approach to get things done
michael keaton great to have you on this
morning thanks for your time
pleasure
now election officials in kenya have
admitted that they are taking too long
in counting votes from last week's
presidential election
verification of ballots has been stopped
several times by challenges from
both candidates our africa correspondent
yusra elbager is in the capital 9 ruby
so good to see you this morning so what
an f is going on when are we likely to
get some kind of results
i mean after what's felt like a very
long wait for people here they are now
arranging the tables the vote
verification is now over and people are
waiting for the announcement of the
country's next president now again
people have felt like they've waited a
long time schools school reopening has
been pushed back more days to the end of
the week but they have not passed the
deadline which is tomorrow for the
results to be announced they're still
within the seven day period to
share who will be the next president and
according to the latest verified votes
current deputy president william ruto is
likely to be announced as the country's
next president soon this does come as a
surprise as rylo dinger the former prime
minister was in the lead by six points
in polls in the lead-up to the votes but
we'll see how the country takes the
decision once it's announced
yeshua thanks very much
now
do you remember this particular tune
[Music]
of course the unmistakable sound of game
of thrones three years on from that
finale it's getting a prequel the new
series called house of dragon and so the
dragon premieres tonight and is reported
to have cost 16 million pounds an
episode this guy's entertainment
correspondent claire gregory has been
speaking to some of the cast
i placed my hair up on the iron throne
[Music]
and all the dragons roared as one
the weight of expectation for a tv show
doesn't come much heavier as the first
game of thrones prequel is about to
arrive on our screens highly anticipated
and reported to cost around 16 million
pounds per episode
there's plenty riding on this
throne's left a huge cultural footprint
and we're never going to be able to
to lay the same one but we're trying to
do something original and something
new and something that feels like it's
it's our own
based on george r.r martin's
best-selling novels game of thrones
became arguably the biggest tv series
ever
no matter what viewers thought of that
ending it was really just the beginning
of what will be a huge franchise with
several spin-offs in the works it's a
model we're familiar with thanks to
marvel and to star wars and it means
there's endless opportunities for
prequels and sequels as long as viewers
remain loyal to the throne
and with off-the-scale production design
and a crew of 2 000 people it was always
going to be a challenge making this and
that's before you throw in a pandemic
i've got covered
i mean listen what was already
complicated and hard was made more
complicated hard and we often thought to
ourselves
why on earth are we doing this right now
why can't we wait but the reality is is
you know uh
you have to find a way a woman would not
inherit the iron throne because that is
the order of things
it may be a fantasy series but a story
about women taking power feels
particularly pertinent now there's a
woman looking to rule how do you
convince your electorate your male
subjects that you are not other how do
you do that and i feel like that's
it's kind of yeah i feel like that's a
fundamental question of the work which
is why we wanted to do it
the possibility of a female leader
backstabbing infighting this latest
installment from westeros seems perhaps
not far from westminster but will no
doubt keep audiences bricked claire
gregory sky news
and house of the dragon starks next
monday on sky atlantic and noun tv
so let's move of course from a set of
families fighting to become
fighting to become king and
appropriately enough talk about at the
race to replace boris johnson as
conservative leader and of course prime
minister we're going to take a look at
the latest political polling with the
former president of yougov and of course
political commentator peter counter
peter lovely to catch up with you um
three weeks left can you believe it
let's take ourselves through a couple of
the polls that we've seen in terms of uh
conservative members voting intention
now this one
which our viewers might not just be able
to make out but was taken back between
the 29th of july and the 2nd of august
liz trust 69
well in the lead rishi sunak on 31
comparing contrast though with polling
that was taken you know a few days after
that the the opinion observer uh pulling
from the 8th to the 13th of august
still a considerable margin between the
two butler's trust apparently falling
back slightly i mean what are we to make
of this is this a genuine shift i don't
know neil
great thanks
there are two possible explanations
there may be a bit of truth in both the
first is there has been a shift mind you
a shift from a 38 point lead in yougov
to a 22 point lead in opinion is a
big shift yep if it's if it's a change
the only substantial thing that happened
between the two polls was the sky news
debate which happened after you got
polled before the opinion poll and
anybody who saw it and saw the audience
reaction which was pro-sunec of that
debate well maybe that's maybe that's it
um however the guy who did the opinion
um poll
which came out yesterday the observer
chris curtis used to work with me at
yougov on leadership polls i don't know
if their methods are different or not
but if this is the second possibility
two different companies
slightly different kinds of samples
slightly different methods maybe that's
the difference i may but my guess is
there's been a bit of a shift back to
sunak but a bit of it is differences
between the way pulses operate
this is something that that has
perplexed me throughout i've just come
back from two weeks off so i've not been
looking at the news but occasionally
when i did i was obviously turning into
the political pages and the thing that
always perplexed me is how does a
polling agency work when you are dealing
not with the population at large which
you can obviously make weight depending
on your sample size but a selector how
many of them we don't really know the
ages we don't really know we we can't
split them down demographically so how
does it work well when i was at yougov
um
we had a panel a british panel of more
than five hundred thousand we knew a lot
about them including we would ask them
quite regularly if they were a member of
a political party if so which one and
that enables us to do polls on labour
leadership conservative leadership you
know on one occasion leave them
leadership on elvis um
we knew the biases in our general
example but there's also some academic
information that comes out from time to
time so we know what we think we know
the conservative party members about 40
of them are over 65. we know they're
overwhelmingly white we know that most
of them live in southern england so we
know
something about them and you can plug
those in to the figures um
and all i can say is look at the records
uh when i was at yougov we did two
touring leadership polls got them both
spot on in duncan smith and david
cameron we got labour poll leadership
but we got ed miliband which nobody
expected to be dedicated david miliband
we were the first to say corbyn was out
in front astonished everybody in 2015 i
remember yeah so
so we had a pretty good record so even
if you can't be sure the last three or
four percent i'm sure those polls are
roughly right you know if rishi tsunak
were to win comfortably when the figures
were announced the polling industry
would go into a state of complete shock
i don't think it will well let's talk
about something else that maybe will be
slightly shocking uh the the mail on
sunday poll about who would make the
best prime minister and of course they
selected them from conservative voters
their polling suggests at liz trusts 26
percent rishi sunnah 24 and someone
called boris johnson out in front on on
33
indeed uh boris johnson frances amongst
conservative voters in the opinion poll
showed boris johnson even more popular
amongst conservative party members
here's the problem neil amongst the
general public recent uganda polling
shows that peop overwhelmingly people
think boris johnson he is incompetent he
isn't trustworthy he's actually no good
i would be tempted to say boris
johnson's a marmite figure i think
they'll be unfair on marmite um the
problem is this the conservatives are
now 33 34 35
they need to gain votes to win the next
election boris johnson is undoubtedly
popular with the conservative base
but the base isn't large enough and he's
very unpopular with pretty well
everybody who's not in the conservative
base so boris johnson holds the tory
party together but he may not win the
tories the votes they need if they're
going to stay in office at the next
election you've got 15 seconds if that
lead is 22 for for for for liz trust
even if it's if it is any larger than
that can you see you're making a bit can
you see rishi soon making it back up uh
in the time game no the sun on sunday
yesterday said 80 percent of tourists
have already voted if there's anything
like that it's all over